you do such great impressions you do
Adelle oh yes Wynonna Judd Sarah
Huckabee sinners you do such great
impressions yeah is there you know I was
reading about you today and there was an
article that said that your dream
impression according to you is Newman
from Seinfeld yes that makes no sense to
me yeah I don't know I guess I see the
resemblance in my heart but you know
what actually happened was I was walking
like the red carpet for this movie the
big sick and this woman was sort of like
they were asking me questions and one
woman yelled out like what what's your
dream impression and I just panicked it
was like she didn't really mean it not I
just it just came from me yeah and then
I noticed it was like they were like
touting it as like an exclusive online
where like eighty Bryant reveals her one
impression she's dying to do yeah and
they were like it's Newman from Seinfeld
yeah there's a tweet I think that you
did about is this you now here yeah this
is what they post it's an exclusive like
it's so insane reveal she's dying to
play yeah and then I love this photo
combo because not only is it Newman but
it's Newman eating chicken yeah that's
what you get for making up stuff on the
red carpet they take it all so seriously
you